so we're all celebrating the 20th
anniversary of the release of legally
blonde and my reaction to legally blonde
is one of the most watched videos on my
channel so i thought i'd take this
opportunity to talk about what's
accurate about this fantastic legal
movie
girls i'm going to harvard first of all
a non-pre-law major gets into law school
yes it happens all the time
law schools hate the fact that they're
always accepting pre-law and poli sci
majors they like
variety well sir we've never had one
before and aren't we always looking for
diversity
elle woods scores almost a perfect score
on the lsat and gets into harvard law
yes if you score as high as she did on
the lsat you'll probably get into
harvard law
welcome to harvard harvard law uses the
socratic method to terrorize students
yes
all the time most law schools still do
it no it's not a good teaching method
but they still do it and l woods faces
sexual harassment in the legal field
are you hitting on me you're a beautiful
girl yes that still happens
yes it is still despicable hopefully
we'll drive this out of the legal
profession but that is legally blonde
what's accurate 20 years later